on en parle tout de suite avec alexis
poulain dans son édito
[Musique]
bonsoir alexis merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france emmanuel macron
fait petit campagne avec l'argent des
français sans mauvais esprit
oui clairement il a le chéquier et c'est
le nôtre et il est en train de faire
beaucoup de cadeaux à toutes les
professions la vue transport police
sage femme qui était qui attendait à une
revalorisation salariale alors il y
avait déjà des dépenses qui était dans
les tuyaux mais clairement depuis
marseille on a l'impression qu'il a
compris que en signant des chèques en
blanc en disant que s'il est réélu il y
aura des grands plans pour la police et
autres eh bien ils risquent d'être aimé
par tout ces professions qui attendent
des moyens mais attention cet argent ce
n'est pas forcément des moyens réels il
reste que toujours qu'on a des manques
de bras dans certains secteurs avec une
tension c'est difficile de recruter
aujourd'hui par exemple dans le secteur
du soin ça reste délicat difficile et on
voit bien que emmanuel macron lui a
besoin de chercher à séduire ses
différentes professions il est partout à
la fois auprès des agriculteurs pour
relancer les sommets du climat auprès de
la police on a l'impression qu'il n'ait
jamais à l'elysée qu'il ne traite jamais
les dossiers urgents et patatras voilà
que ces sous marins n'ont pas été signés
c'est un énorme échec peut-être qu'ils
devraient se concentrer sur son travail
régalien de chef de l'état de garant des
institutions et arrêter d'être en
campagne permanente surtout avec notre
argent alors on va en parler d'eric
zemmour également cette hypothèse et
moore haskell rebat les cartes
aujourd'hui clairement alors on voit
bien il n'ya pas qu'ils modèlent macron
qui est en campagne évidemment eric
zemmour qui est en semi campagne
puisqu'il n'est toujours pas candidat
officiel mais tout porte à croire qu'il
va se présenter certains seraient même
en train de chercher des signatures pour
avoir les 500 signatures il fait la
tournée
pour la vente de son livre en termes de
marketing c'est formidable eric zemmour
il va même jusqu'à
invectivé le chef de l'état dans ces
vidéos sur twitter on en voit là cette
bande de sous-marins ce qu'un échec un
fiasco énorme qu'ont fait les services
secrets français ben on se demande je
pense qu'ils ont travaillé mais
malheureusement ils n'ont peut-être pas
été entendu en tout cas on voit que eric
zemmour a l'intention de précipiter
bouger bousculer la campagne
présidentielle de d'un prix mais ça
marque les choix aussi des thèmes et
d'ailleurs il y en a un qui choisit de
débattre avec lui deux candidats c'est
jean luc mélenchon 1 demain sur une
chaîne concurrente un grand débat pour
justement mettre les idées sur la table
et pour sans doute essayer de voler la
vedette à tous les autres candidats et
dire nous sommes en campagne peut-être
qu'il exhume on ne l'est pas encore mais
jean-luc mélenchon du moins prêteuses
ceci et prend aussi le pas pour dire moi
aussi je voudrais que mes thèmes et bien
un prime la campagne on cherchait
simplement à faire de la vue c'est ce
qui va se passer eric zemmour en tout
cas on en a beaucoup parlé la semaine
dernière on va voir à partir de sa
déclaration de candidature ce qui va se
passer parce que on attend toujours un
programme toujours une équipe toujours à
des idées jusqu'à présent ça reste du
marketing pour vendre un livre pour les
autres alexis début de campagne
difficile avec plus ou moins de succès
selon prix mais envers primaire hidalgo
est évidemment le ps alors oui il ya on
voit qu'il ya différentes façons de
faire chez les verts le
la première manche de la primaire est
passée et du chapeau sont sortis yannick
jadot et sandrine rousseau deux
candidats très différents un sandrine
rousseau qui joue sur l'éco féminisme
des thèmes plutôt radicaux proches de
l'histoire des dévers de ce parti
contestataire tel qu'il était et yannick
jadot qui présente la face plus
présentable officiel député européen qui
est prêt à faire beaucoup de concessions
et qui se voit déjà candidat à la
présidentielle donc on verra comment les
membres inscrits à la primaire des verts
vont départager ces deux candidats mais
ça a permis aux verts de d'être sur le
devant de la scène et de parler beaucoup
d'eux et de leurs idées chez l air la
primaire c'est plutôt un caillou dans la
chaussure il s'agit de savoir comment la
faire sous quelle forme essayer
d'évacuer le souci le problème avec un
xavier bertrand qui lui refusent de
participer à la primaire puisqu'il n'est
plus chez à l'air mais qui se veut
candidat officiel de la droite quand
même alors que valérie pécresse elle
aussi voudrait être candidate officielle
de la droite tout ça extrêmement
compliqué ça dessert plutôt ce parti
républicain qui a du mal à statuer sur
les primaires et puis au ps et le
congrès étaient passés sous les radars
quasiment olivier faure a été réélu à la
tête du secrétariat général du parti
socialiste et lui il continue à faire le
en même temps c'est à dire qu'on ferme
un peu la porte on ouvre et puis là il a
dit clairement que le ps en tant
qu'appareil se mettrait derrière la
candidature dany d'algos qui anne
hidalgo n'avait pas fait le déplacement
au congrès pour éviter de fâcher les
autres éléphants notamment stéphane le
foll qui est assez seul à vouloir une
primaire au ps alors que on voit bien
que le parti s'achemine vers un soutien
au moins du bout des lèvres à la
candidature dany d'algos et et puis il
ya tous les autres candidats dont je
parlais jean luc mélenchon déclaré
depuis longtemps fabien roussel qui
essaye aussi de se positionner tout ça
est extrêmement délicat on voit bien que
cette campagne présidentielle va
s'accélérer aujourd'hui on est un peu
dans un entre deux où chacun essaye de
prendre la lumière ou de se faire
oublier de préparer ses troupes et ses
équipes mais on est loin encore d'un
débat d'idées important pour départager
les candidats -le pour savoir ce qui va
se passer par la suite aujourd'hui ça
reste quand même de la mise en scène et
du buzz médiatique à voir quel buzz va
servir ou desservir quel candidat
feuilleton continuera évidemment et on
suivra avec vous alexis couleurs plus
que ça pourra tenir
méfiez-vous va pas s'ennuyer